los nacionalistas escoceses iniciaron
hoy su camino para buscar la
independencia del reino unido- la
ministra principal escocesa nicola
sturgeon fijó propuso como el 19 de
octubre de 2023 la fecha para realizar
un segundo referendo de independencia
con la misma pregunta de 2014 debe ser
escocia un país independiente el camino
político está completamente despejado
porque esto lyon tiene las mayorías en
el parlamento de esa región pero
jurídicamente
londres el gobierno central debe dar la
aprobación del gobierno johnson ha dicho
que este no es el momento oportuno para
un segundo referendo por ello la primera
ministra escocesa ha consultado con la
corte suprema para establecer si habría
impedimentos jurídicos para realizar
esta consulta sin el visto bueno de
londres y los hay ha dicho entonces las
próximas elecciones generales se
convertirán en un referéndum de facto
pese a que aún no hay fecha para estas
elecciones porque su partido los
nacionalistas escoceses sólo harán
campaña y promesa de independizarse del
reino en el 2014 el 55% de la población
escocesa votó por mantenerse dentro del
reino unido con la promesa de que este
país se mantendría dentro de la unión
europea
nicola sturgeon ha dicho hoy que escocia
no será prisionera de boris johnson ni
tampoco de ningún otro primer ministro